- [Mark] All right, Mike and Tina?
- Yes.
- [Mark] Mike and Tina, where
are you guys from originally?
- [Mike] I'm from Boston.
- [Tina] I'm from Missouri.
- You guys met how long ago?
- [Tina] Back three years ago?
- [Mike] Three, Yeah. Almost
- [Mark] Mike, tell me about
your childhood in Boston.
- My whole family's from there.
My dad passed away when I was five.
Since then it's been going back there
in summertimes.
But I was going back there in summertimes
to see my grandparents, to
live with them for the summers.
- [Mark] So you lost your dad early?
- Yup, yup.
- [Mark] How was your childhood?
- It was good.
It was good, but it was
two separate families.
It was my dad's side.
And then my mom's side and
both sides drank
and this is one side was like
completely different than the other.
One played cards and
they worked at Boston University.
They were in a union,
I don't know , they just seem
different than my mom's side.
I just remember remembering
that difference.
Sometimes it was a little harder
to be around my mom's side of
the family for some reason.
Not much harder but just different,
in uncomfortable way.
- [Mark] But how would you
describe your childhood?
- It was,
a lot of trying to fit in,
just trying to fit in a lot.
I've felt like I was misplaced.
- [Mark] No serious abuse or?
- No, no, no serious abuse.
Just my mom drinking,
it wasn't in it, when she got drunk
it wasn't bad until like they would fight.
So my stepdad, whom she remarried,
would fight with my mom.
And then once they fought,
it was like just a bunch of stuff
and it usually would end up my mom saying,
I'm leaving, I'm gonna go
kill myself, which is ironic,
cause I said that a lot to her.
She would leave the house and
I don't know, I remember my mom
not coming back one time
my little brother,
and I was looking out the window
and like wondering if,
she was gonna come home
like she said, she was
going to kill herself.
- [Mark] How old were you?
- Probably about 12 or something.
Something like that,
maybe 10, I don't know.
- [Mark] That's could've
been hard for a young man
to deal with.
- Yes, it was hard,
cause I didn't really, like
I didn't think about it a lot
until like, it was just me
and my brother and I
just thinking about like,
I don't know, I just picture
us looking at the windows.
Then my mom, like we moved
around a lot in Virginia Beach.
That's where they separated,
my stepdad, and my mom.
And that's where
we stopped moving from state to state.
I graduated high school there and
I just tried to stay,
I did a lot of
staying away from home.
Like just, it was basketball,
mostly I skateboarding
but mostly basketball
cause I broke or fractured my
wrist twice to skateboarding.
- [Mark] And what kind
of jobs have you had?
- Well, I've had mostly waiting
tables jobs, to be honest
I've been in the military.
I was in the army.
I went off to VCU, like barely
made it into college for art
drawing was like my medium.
But
I got kicked out of the dorms for a weed
and then
getting caught with the bong,
so that led to me joining the military
because the guy said he
could beat my weed charge
and I was like, cool,
I need some discipline.
Everybody told me not to go.
But I'm the type that
doesn't listen to that
and just goes.
So I went on a delayed
entry and got kicked out
of that too. I rebelled but then,
I don't know, I got to,
like out of bootcamp
and into the AIT in Maryland
Aberdeen Proving Grounds.
Then I
got kicked out and sold weed for awhile,
like for a long time and
got pretty good at that,
my life was like a movie during that time.
And then everybody wants to cocaine
and things like that.
So I didn't really, I was
scared of the time that was
attached to it, so
I started waiting tables
and I'm trying to get sober.
And that's, when...
- Tina, tell me about your, your life.
Did you grow up where?
- In Missouri.
- And how was your family?
- I grew up poor, but I
didn't really know it.
We were,
it was my mom and dad, they're
still married to this day
and then I have two brothers
older, one older, one younger
but
very happy childhood,
nothing too traumatic happen.
I just remember my parents struggling,
and working a lot.
So I spent a lot of time with my brothers
but
I can't really say that I had any
similar experiences in my childhood
like anything, he went through.
- [Mark] What kind of work have you done?
- I'm a registered nurse.
So at high school, I went
straight into college
and then
nursing school, graduated nursing school.
Then I
have just worked in the nursing field
for the past since 2004,
but
I don't know,
I started out in a burn
unit and intensive care,
I loved doing that.
Later on, I was working with
elderly people,
people who had behavioral health issues,
mental health issues.
And
up until a few years ago,
I had
gotten a job as an overnight manager.
I did the hiring, firing,
Medicare, Medicaid
Compliance stuff like that,
which was a lot more in my speed.
But
I had a pretty, pretty typical
I guess wealthiness childhood, you know.
- [Mark] And drugs came into
the picture when for you guys?
- For me, it came in, I
think I did acid it first.
And that was probably,
I was in high school.
On a weekend, I did acid
one time and I loved it
secretly, but I knew my mom was a drinker.
So I promised myself I would never,
I would never become like my mom.
I promised myself that I would, I would
if I had a son, then I would
always be there for him.
And
you know,
drugs took care of making
those things really
difficult to --
- [Mark] Do you guys have kids?
- Yes. I have a son, Sebastian.
- [Mark] And who's taking care of him?
- That's why I'm in California.
His Mom and Dad and his and her mom.
She's from Russia.
She's here in LA County.
- [Mark] So you can visit him sometimes.
- Yeah. That's what we're trying to do.
I've been in California for a while,
I've been distracted
very, very forcefully.
At times, not that I need it personally,
it doesn't take much for me to
out stretch myself, honestly,
but I've been
so I've been in California for a long time
and haven't this time haven't seen my son
for almost a year now,
but it was six years
five years before that.
- [Mark] And Tina, to do your kids?
- Yeah, I have two kids.
I have a son and a daughter
and they're both back.
We met in Virginia Beach, actually.
And they're still in Virginia
Beach with their father
who was my high school sweetheart.
We had divorced shortly
before I met Mike,
but
they're a little bit older,
they're still out there.
- [Mark] But you raised them
for a big part of their lives?
- Yeah, I was a stay at
home mom for a little while,
and my,
my ex-husband was gone a lot,
so it was just me and the kids,
(coughs)
probably 90% of the time.
Thank you.
And I had quit working
because my son had some special needs.
And then,
I just thought that I had the
perfect life for a long time.
And then I found out
on Christmas Eve 2016,
that he had a
girlfriend on the side
for a very long time
and I'm not the kind of
person who's gonna take it,
That ended our marriage.
And I was okay with that,
like
we were better friends than
we were husband and wife, but
I've been alone for so long.
Cause I left all my family back home,
moved out to San Diego
with him for his job, and
kind of followed him around the country,
and
didn't have any, I don't talk a lot,
I liked to talk about
what's going on in my life.
I started drinking and
found that I was able to
cope a lot better
with all the sudden, being a
single parent of special needs,
kid and I have to go back
to work after being out
of work for awhile and
started drinking and drinking a lot.
And the next thing you knew, I was
a year later,
closet drinking a fifth of
vodka, five liter box of wine
as many beers as I could
get ahold of every day,
and ended up in the hospital
for about 14, 15 days
after I tried to kill myself.
And to that,
and then I had a DUI during that time
that led me into A.A.,
which A.A.,
led me to meet people who
introduced me to this,
the world of drugs, this world
that I'm living in now.
And I'd not even experienced that
until I was 36 years old, I guess.
- [Mark] So you're living a very
straight life up until just recently?
- Very recently.
The year before,
I guess,
man, 2017,
I wanna say, I made
my, you know, tax return
looked really good,
and that I had done that on my own.
I got myself right up to six figures
almost, like I had almost
broken that barrier.
That was by myself.
That was when I was drinking
heavy too, but I've never,
I've smoked weed once when I was 18.
And that was it.
That was my experience
with the world of drugs.
But then,
I get a DUI,
the judge sentenced me to go to A.A.
which I thought was a blessing.
And I would still argue that it was,
but
those people introduced me to crystal meth
and heroin, and all the things that
now have become a part
of my everyday life.
And here I am.
- [Mark] And you guys
are living on the street?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Here in Skid Row?
Yes, yeah.
I pretty much came in to,
I feel like
guess I feel like I came in,
I'm those people that came in and
introduced her to those drugs.
She knew about them, but when
we met at an A.A. meeting
and I mean, I don't
like telling people that
but I tell people that because
it's kind of a unique thing
and it's something to warn you about
in meetings and things like that.
But I never had done that like ever.
I was just coming out of that
relationship with Olga and
that was five years, and we had Sebastian,
she was in a relationship for 13 years
and we've met that day
and have like a Star Wars
shirt on with like a C3PO?
Or R2D2, whoever's the
shorter one, is it R2D2?
C3PO? One of them, it's
the white one that's short,
not the gold tall one,
I had that on my shirt.
And I remember that.
I remember her
being
beautiful
and, but I was shy and I
didn't say nothing to her.
And we talked after the
meeting just briefly,
and I cut that short and flipped off.
And then we ended up 12
step and my friend Harry,
who was like relapsed and,
we brought him to the hospital
and she was the ride.
Some girls like, this girl
was like, I'll bring them,
I call my friend or whatever.
I'll give you a ride
and she'll pick us up,
I'll take care of you to the hospital.
And Harry has like puke
all over him and stuff.
And he looked all, not like himself
and like, different cold-hearted,
and we took him to the
hospital, and me and her,
like literally stayed
together since then every day,
like every day we can
possibly, she's torn away
and had some breaks, but like,
I'm not even sure that
like, those are her,
all her intentions.
Like I think sometimes just God
has a way of splitting us up
and like Timeout, you know,
from, cause we go through
we've been through a lot.
There's probably 12 books
we could write just on
stuff since we've been in California.
- [Mark] Do you guys find
this kind of connection
with the fact that you've been through,
you went through a divorce,
Tina and you, went
through a tough childhood.
You guys kind of
- I do.
I feel
- Not for me, though.
- I do, I see that, but I
think it's cool that you don't.
- Yeah, see, like I did a lot of hiding
when I was growing up.
I was the middle child.
I was the only girl and I
just always
tried to be
the person that people
I thought needed me to be.
And that came from some,
I don't even know where it came out of,
but I didn't even really notice how much
it affected my everyday life
until I met
Mike and then some of
our other friends, but
I've played orchestra in high school
or actually school all three school,
as long as I could.
You know, I'm a nurse, I did
swimming for a little while,
everything that I did,
youth group at church,
I was always at church.
I can say that I was never truly happy
doing any of it, but I did it.
And I did it to the best of my abilities
and I've succeeded in most
of it, but I just always felt
like I wasn't
able to just say, here I am, this is me.
And it's nothing that,
it's not like my family did anything wrong
to make me feel like that.
But
I remember
at the end of my marriage
feeling like the odd duck,
I didn't care about fitting in
and keeping up with everybody else.
I don't care about your,
how much your house
costs or your car costs.
Like I wouldn't know like who you are.
I just like, couldn't
meet anybody who I felt
like I had a real, human connection with.
It all felt like plastic to me.
And that might've been
where I was in my life.
- [Mark] Did you feel that
you're having that with Mike now?
- No, not at all.
As soon as I met him, I tried so hard
to not let him know who I was, man.
I would lie to him about
things that happened growing up.
I would use make up, stupid stuff,
just cause I did not want
him to know that real me
and he always, like, he just
saw straight through it.
- I remembered.
I was like, why she lying
about this little stupid stuff.
Usually I wouldn't even deal with that.
And I'd be like,
I'm not going to be able
to like be with you.
I would have a hard time with that.
But like, I don't know.
When the day I met her I felt like
I was gonna kill myself that day too.
So it was just weird.
I just was hung over and it was like
I remember I was busing tables
at a job that I waited tables at.
And like they were telling
me they don't need me cause
of my performance as busting tables.
And I was like, are you kidding me?
I didn't think I had that bad of a day.
That was just like, Oh my God.
She was the only bright spot in
my world at all that right then.
But pain and suffering
I think we do have a common bond in that.
I think that,
even though she, at times
doesn't want to admit to being
or doesn't admit to being
an addict or an alcoholic,
I think that that's our
common bond between us
is that we understand that part of us
but,
what we yet have to do
have done together
is show 'em that
we can have the common
bond of recovery too.
Although we don't have
to be totally abstinent
if we're not like, if we're
somehow missing something
and we can still dabble,
and have a regular life
which I don't know about that,
I'm pretty sure we can't.
But, anyways, my point to that was,
I think that we're right
now, like to this moment
I think
it's like a halfway point of like where
we start picking up the
pieces and start putting,
trying to get to my son's
town, and get presentable
in front of people to where I can
feel better about myself
and not have some cuts,
- He does that a lot.
and torture
- All this things going on in my head.
I mean, it's not like
- It took me like two and a half years
before I realized some
of the problems that he
and I have had together is that,
he didn't feel like he was
worthy of anything basically
but he definitely didn't feel
like he deserved to be with me.
And I kind of felt the same way.
- I, I was scared.
I often walked into their house
they're going through a divorce,
I would have to move.
She was moving from her four bedroom house
to her apartment by herself
after the 13-year marriage.
And I'm like, Oh, this is sad.
Like, I felt bad
and I was going through some crap too,
but I had been single
for a couple of years.
So I do move and walked into her house
and saw pictures of her kids
and like, I see like
her cats running around
kinda taking over the place a little bit.
And I see the mess on the counter
and I could see an old bottle of liquor.
I just saw this stuff and I was
like, dude, like that sucks.
I remember when I was in my house,
I was walking through,
it's like a haunted house
man is like, everything is making me cry.
Everything has a story, every piece of
furniture and stuff like,
so I helped her move
and move all that stuff.
I was just so scared that
we're gonna lose everything.
Even then, I didn't tell her that,
I lived in a homeless shelter at the time,
and the only, I think the reason
why I really jumped the gun
and tried to move in with her was because
she's such a nice people pleaser.
She asked Harry or told
Harry that if you want
you can crash at my house,
I'm doing weekends in jail or whatever,
I guess what she was saying,
I just pictured Harry getting with her
And I was like, let me
try to rearrange that
because it got that weird.
It started off a relationship and stuff,
so that's what happened.
- [Mark] What is your drug today?
You're using Fentanyl?
- Fentanyl was pretty new as
far as like a choice of drug.
I haven't been to a
place where you can get
powdered Fentanyl ever before this
so, before it was like those blue,
the blues, that thirties
are pressed up Fentanyl
they looked like Oxy 30s, Roxies,
but they're actually Fentanyl.
I did those before, but anyways,
my point to that was a Fentanyl on ice.
- [Mark] And Tina, what are you using?
- About the same, although
there for awhile I was a
little heavier on the Fentanyl
and I've backed off on it now.
It's scary, it's a little too scary,
but yeah, Fentanyl on ice.
- [Mark] How would you
compare your happiness today
to what it was maybe five, 10 years ago?
Tina?
- [Tina] It was crazy, cause
I'm a lot happier with who I am
and a lot happier with
the way I see the world today
than before, the people that I've met out,
on the street and
Mike, and then
it's amazing how
honest they are with
who they are like, this is
who I am this is where I'm at
and take it or leave it.
But here I am.
And I was so not used to
that, that it was like
a blessing to be able to
be around people like that.
Just take me or leave
me, but this is me and
I feel very happy,
and I'm very happy to be
out here with him still.
- Yeah. I really, I really need to
get some
progress on,
so I can make her feel
better about being with me.
I say that because I see
myself in her too, like
a people pleaser would speak,
I just had to make her happy.
I want her to be happy, but I'm not,
I'm not sure how to make myself happy,
or even care about it.
But I'm so selfish too at the same time.
So it's like just weird
and I don't want it to get
worse, but I think that
we're pretty aware of
what our problems are now.
So
we just have yet to
really go full force
into the other direction.
I've been really stubborn,
I'm not giving up my vices
because
of my reasons,
have reasons,
like I feel people forced
me to do stuff a lot
and like in different ways, slick ways.
And I feel like
it's robbing me of my
experience in life, man.
Like it's also prolonging it
but I'm the one prolonging it.
I'm saying that I'm labeling that as that,
and so I'm the one that's being stubborn
and using that as an
excuse to prolong my --
- [Mark] But living in a
tent on the sidewalk is okay?
- To be honest with you,
like I'm living in recovery
it showed me how to use
acceptance almost overly.
So, you know what I mean?
Like acceptance is the
answer to all my problems.
Right? There's that.
Also, if you want to have a life though,
you should probably think about
that statement a little bit,
because you need money too,
and if you wanna have some kids
you should have money too.
I can accept that I can be broken
and I can accept a lot
and be very peaceful
because of,
call them Jedi mind tricks or whatever.
But like,
it's acceptance.
It's just walking through
the day, not labeling things
and I can do that 'til I'm homeless
and I'm nothing.
What I wanna do it without drugs?
Nah, I don't think so.
I think I would've probably
got a new shell
if I was that lobster that
hadn't needed a bigger shell,
and I was using something
to cover up the pain
to feel that I have a small shell.
I probably would've changed shells by now
and grown as a person.
I got out of this rut
instead of furnishing it.
So I think,
I kinda sidetracked
that answer a little bit
but yeah,
I think I'm better with
living in a tent on a sidewalk
than she probably wants to be.
Or maybe if, maybe I'm lying about that
and don't even realize what I'm saying.
- [Mark] What would you say
the most important lesson
you guys have learned?
- Brutal.
- [Mark] You've been through a lot.
- What would you say
most important lesson?
- I know, I know mine.
Do you wanna go first?
- No.
- I've been learning it lately.
It's about priorities and getting like,
never letting her go as far as like,
out of my sight, if I'm
protecting her, but really
what it boils down to.
I kinda wanted to be in that position
if I got my priorities straight.
I thought, I think like if I have,
God, family,
and me,
or whatever,
recovery, whatever how you
want to put it in order.
And I act that way, my
actions, cause I can say it.
If I tell her I love you,
and my actions don't say
I love you, then that's the best I can do.
So like really,
don't take it for granted.
Don't take anything for granted,
like my son, and this and that.
What's ripping me from that?
So like I gotta structure my priorities.
- [Mark] Tina, what
would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned?
- Taking responsibility
isn't always just about,
like saying I'm taking responsibility
for my actions or like this
is, you know, it's my fault.
It means a lot more than that
because you can be
response --
you can think you're
taking responsibility for
your actions but holding
a lot of grudges against
people and a lot of hatred
and resentment that you
don't even know about,
when in reality,
you know where you're
at cause you're there
and you can just
deal with it or just
continue being angry, and
making choices that are
gonna, like, he says
delay the suffering.
If you just let it go and realize,
I am where I am, because
that's where God has me now.
And that's what God
wanted me to go through.
And you know, it's because
of all of this that,
I'm where I'm at now, it's a lot.
It makes the outlook seem not so dim
because you realize,
my whole future
could have been just
continuing to stack on
these resentment and pain,
and suffering that you didn't know about.
But then you get here on the
street, you're brought so low
to where you're broken and
you kinda open your eyes
and realize like, I'm
not even mad at them.
I just need to let that go
and be okay with me
and move on from it.
And it's kind of amazing how
much relief you get from that.
I mean, it sounds simple, but it's not.
Because you can say you
got to like be broken
and get to the bottom of the barrel,
before you can recover.
But
it's very easy to say
but sometimes the lowest
point that you're at
you think there's no
worse, it can get worse.
- [Mark] All right, Mike and Tina,
Thank you so much for sharing your story.
I wish you guys the best of
luck out there in the street.
- Thank you.
- Thank you very much.